there I want to go back to Molly line
who has new information on what's
happening outside of card's house at
this moment Molly what can you tell
us yeah just a little more information
that they are appealing directly to
Robert and anyone else in the house
continuing to urge them to come out of
the house if they are inside you know
it's also worth noting that throughout
the day we've seen police and tactical
deal particularly over in those areas in
the lisban area and Beyond down south
down in the area of where that family
compound as as it's been described as is
Loc multiple structures there in this
area but they seem to be focused in on
one particular home there on the
property again a megaphone directly
appealing uh to Robert to anyone else in
the house and they continue uh to urge
someone to come out essentially
peacefully to to draw to a to draw to a
safe conclusion uh and and that's where
we're just waiting to hear more now and
and and seeing wondering how much more
you know I I'm trying to keep an idea of
if assets are beginning to grow greater
in that area and I'll keep you posted on
that Laura all right Molly thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else